now a hundred days into total democrat
control of dc and it's apparent
who joe biden's main booster is well the
u.s media of course now to see what i
mean
let's compare their treatment of joe
biden's first hundred days
versus donald trump's here's joe at a
hundred
whether or not you like the policy it's
been an extraordinary first 100 days
he's approaching
the first 100 days he's trying to build
and sustain political momentum for his
approach
to say we've done it uh for the first uh
uh on in terms of the pandemic to try to
bring down the temperature
in an overheated washington uh inflamed
by his predecessor donald trump
uh he's trying to reach out in a
bipartisan fashion
now compare the fawn fest for biden
to what they did to donald trump
why the first 100 days been so chaotic
the first hundred days of disaster
it seems like there is a lot of
failure domestically the president has
no real milestone legislative
achievement no real legislative
achievement at all
he's at record low approval ratings
you could feel the love couldn't you
joining me now newt gingrich former
house speaker fox news contributor newt
now they've always been in the tank for
the left and the democrats but right now
it's just
it's now gotten to the point where
they're advancing
both dangerous and anti-constitutional
anti-american policies at the same time
sure but that that's been the natural
evolution of the modern
american news media they started on the
left
they've now gone further to the left
they have a president
who even aoc has said has been more
radical
than she could have hoped for they've
had a hundred days which i think are the
most radical
100 days of any president in modern
times
maybe in history unless you count
lincoln's presiding over the beginning
of a civil war
and a lot of their records a disaster
we've had more
illegal immigrants in the first three
months
of biden than in all of last year
think about that we have in one quarter
we
passed last year's total for illegal
immigration
we've had the largest increase in
murders uh
you were covering it brilliantly earlier
uh we've had
a huge increase in in shootings that are
not fatal
we've had a huge increase in
carjackings and in rapes we have an
administration
that in terms of basic policies is doing
almost everything it can
to undermine and weaken america and i
think
that almost none of that will be covered
by the news media
because they are totally committed to
protecting biden
just as they did for the whole campaign
and so they don't want to report any of
these things
and i'm looking forward to his speech
because i'm curious
i mean is he going to deal with anything
that's real or is it just going to be
more
left-wing rhetoric to set up another
left-wing program
to spend more of the taxpayers money on
left-wing interest groups
yeah that's certainly been the pattern
up till now yeah you mentioned the
hyping the address tomorrow to congress
joint session uh
and here's how they did it over at msnbc
president biden delivers his first
address to a joint
session of congress tomorrow and the
white house tells nbc news he is quote
deeply involved in its development new
deeply involved because they they said
that a lot about
president trump who actually would x out
big portions of his remarks and change
them and do it on
off the cuff when he had to
here's the most fascinating to me as a
former speaker of the house
the most fascinating aspect of tomorrow
night
they're only going to have 200 people in
the entire room
now this this is a room which can easily
hold virtually a thousand or more people
but they have decided for coveted
reasons and this is a president whose
pathological concern about kovid is
almost bizarre
for coveted reasons the each party 50
house
republicans 50 house democrats 50 senate
democrats
50 senator republicans that's it
house members got a note that said if
you're not on the invitation let's don't
come
because we won't let you in this is
going to be the weirdest
congressional speech by a president in
american history it's going to be a
virtually empty room
and i think it tells you a lot about
this administration
uh you have a basically empty symbolic
administration
presiding over the amazing destructive
levels
of what's happening in american society
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else